hello and welcome to this video playing
mmm mmm to ditch hmm yeah you never know
okay I'm happy to be back again with
some blitz games I haven't done games
the last three days or so I've been
extremely busy over the weekend because
we had the start of our Club chess
season and yeah that means I was busy
whole the whole Sunday and they had
other obligations on Saturday it was
really tough to get any time and for a
video or any videos so back now with
some blitz chess
okay I've could have I've got a French
exchange here where black played
somewhat unusual setup with Knight to c6
combined with Knight f6 then it's not
really commonly seen it's probably
playable like how bad can there be for
black it it's probably never going to be
terrible but I think I'm quite
comfortable simply because the knight is
not well placed on c6 aha now he tries
to to unpin that feels very logically
the knight is supposed to move and then
we're going to trade bishops I guess
soon early in the morning so how to play
this maybe night here maybe 90 I am
anticipating that there will be a good
square on c5 after the trade
you may be ok interesting in this
particular case I don't need to trade I
can just withdraw the bishop and keep it
on the board
aha
ok so he allows the damaging of his pawn
structure there again that's not the end
of the world
no not by any stretch but ok not unhappy
I can't I want to prevent Bishop g4 here
then I to be for yes it's the idea for
black but I have to definitely take into
account where do I go with the Queen
yeah Queen runs into a discovery maybe
not immediately but it is on the cards
yeah maybe Queen d1 or simply retreat
ain't gone I need to regroup the night
why go here now let's start with this I
mean preventing that before in that way
yeah that was kind of clear Bishop takes
h3 it's a threat
whenever playing for him what kind of
trades for example what kind of end game
probably probably not
oh yes g5 I was really a bit curious for
th8 was supposed to do but now we know
okay
g5l Gorge for
huh Wow
Wow okay yeah I hope my assessment is
correct that I'm going to be the one to
attack rook edge one and I have the
excellent f5 square at least in most
cases that should be mine okay so Bishop
f5 is it's the thing on 9h five wins the
Queen if I get this off night H - how
does he cover that he cannot cover the
bishop and if he retreats it there is
not h5 so this is strong Queen f4 there
is Bishop f5 and there is also over I
think
Knight takes d4 is there something like
that
miracle chess might be 94 Nagi 492 a
knight f6 okay this is 94 is just
irritating okay I only have 15 seconds
this is this is the other way to do it
don't believe this crap okay so yeah I
made a big fork then that's unbelievable
how how how I don't know it's really
really crazy and maybe I could have done
something better I was on six seconds
I'm sorry so
King D six that just about holding now
he's got King e7 crazy don't know if
this is right or would be seven now each
six was probably even stronger but the
game is going to have the result that it
is supposed to have somehow okay so
let's have a look
yeah 96 I'm a little bit I don't think
this is good to be honest it's just not
an ammonia setup okay so we could hear
that's very very conventional a six
month I know if Bishop b5 was a threat
but so no he went Bishop to e7 I think
this this makes sense Jenny wants to
probably trade trade this piece and not
so much about the trade but to get them
to get out of the pin 93 9:27 and this
is debatable
I went Bishop g3 because it feels like
he's a little bit clocked up but you can
definitely also just take and claim that
yeah I know how he captures this one and
claim that yeah the resulting position
is a little bit better white that would
be correct I think I have the better
Bishop and blacks pieces slightly
slightly misplaced nothing terrible but
it's a little bit of something as you
see the engine gives white already
something sizable and 0.6 is not bad
okay Bishop g3 this is the more logical
move and okay I went for this age 3
because Bishop g4 I don't know it fits
into the position rook c8 maybe now
we're grouping but a 3 cannot be
terrible Queen f6
and I'd pity too I think and this is all
very very make sense and now he went for
this somewhat crazy plan with King h8
maybe I'm maybe I'm not fair to this
plane but it feels it feels weird to me
so maybe night g3 is stronger as the
computer suggests yeah so let's say G
form then I take takes and then Queen to
b3 just being very materialistic about
it I mean yeah there is no real attack
black has no attack the Knights are not
taking part and it takes a bit of time
to get them over okay two point seven SS
you Jim so maybe that wasn't the best
idea but I think it should keep an
advantage and the engine disagreed I
just wanted to make sure that yeah I'm
I'm on on those squares and okay h5 I
felt should backfire ni g3 take take
take and adapted that's a disaster
King G 2 so in know Knight age too yeah
it should win but I didn't I didn't I
didn't find it I could quit a forum yeah
I I don't know my clock was down here to
18 seconds though and I can just take it
why didn't that take it I panicked
actually panicked
I can just take the night what what what
was I thinking this is just extremely
simple Queen III is ridiculous yeah yeah
I mean I was panicking but at least the
position is so better for me
okay 97 is quite obvious I still missed
it okay I have to make quick Mawson
somewhere I mean he's a pawn up but the
black position has no coordination so I
was fairly confident that I'm not worse
but now I'm I'm winning him Oh 6v6
and that that wins yeah it's just it's
just too much rugby 7s better than
wooden Knight f5 mmm okay it doesn't you
shouldn't go to him seven clear of
course and then that gave it away
immediately Knight h6 is even a bit
better my seven and now I wanted to take
yeah it's better I'm not winning but
it's it's better for white of course um
should simply take on d4 but yeah I
don't know early in the day I have no
clue what I was thinking okay guys
thanks for watching